all right thanks jc it's time to
vanquish with me jazzy they're here to
help you get your ideal body
britney black is here to tell us how hey
brittany
hi hi okay so we're talking about body
sculpting
with vanquish me getting rid of stubborn
fat
permanently people are loving this
treatment you guys are telling us so
tell me why they're loving it
how does it work so it has two different
technologies
in one machine it has fat reducing
technology which permanently kills the
fat and it also has skin tightening
technology
so it doesn't make any contact with the
skin even huh so how does it actually
feel then
you feel just a mild warmth so it
sometimes
you'll feel a little bit of warmth
sometimes you won't even feel anything
depending on your sensitivity
okay and what people are really loving
the fact that it's permanent the
vanquish me destroys fat cells like you
said and once they're gone
they are gone for good right yep
completely killed
wow and how long does the treatment
actually take
about 45 minutes to an hour depending on
what areas we're doing
okay and i see we're looking at some
before and after pictures oh what a
difference what
what areas can you treat with this
any big area is so mostly stomach thighs
arms back bra area
all the trouble all the problem areas
that men and women have and how many
treatments are needed
to complete the process
typically between four to six depending
on what we're looking for but on your
first session you'll see something
okay that's good to know and how quickly
will i see results or will someone see
results
so same day we'll see a little bit of
something but it does take up to 21
days for the fat to fully flesh out okay
so you'll be getting
better and better every single day for
21 days
wow okay brittany thank you so much
that's definitely something good to know
before we head into the new year right
yes get those resolutions and now
exactly all right thanks so much
brittany
the jazzy wellness guarantees you will
lose two inches or more
same day with their vanquish me series
okay they're offering 40
off to their first 10 callers right now
call 800-702-800-7406 or find them
online
at bejazzywellness.com